the saudi crown prince mohammed bin
salman is visiting turkey for the first
time since the 2018 murder of the
journalist jamal khashoggi in istanbul
relations between the two countries have
been tense since the killing but
regional and financial challenges have
forced ankara and riyadh to repair their
ties
let's get more on this we can speak to
resources live for us in ankara so talk
us through the significance of this trip
well it is a major step in repairing uh
strange relations between uh saudi
arabia and turkey so the relationships
between these two muslim powerhouses in
the region
have been stained
after the arab spring in 2011 these two
countries have supported different
political movements across the region
and saudi arabia united arab emirates
and egypt so the the actors that turkey
is supporting the region as a threat to
the balance of the power
in the region and then in 2017
a blockade over one of the key ally of
turkey qatar has been declared by the
gulf countries and that has further
pushed the the two countries saudi
arabia and turkey apart however it was
the killing of the saudi journalist
jamal khashoggi in kingdoms consulate in
istanbul in 2018 that firmly shut down
the relations between the two countries
turkey has launched a case against 26
saudi suspects and saudi arabia
responded by boycotting turkish products
putting a a pressure over the over the
turkish economy however
last year turkey has initiated or
embarked on a diplomatic push to reach
to reset its relations with saudi arabia
and then an istanbul court uh that has
uh has just halted the trial in
essential of these 26 saudi suspects
paving the way for a meeting between the
turkish and the saudi leaders in the
same month we have seen that erdogan
went to riyadh and met the king the king
salman and the crown prince mohammed bin
salman as well and now muhammad bin
salman the crown prince of saudi arabia
is returning this wizard and it's being
seen as another step in uh in the
normalizations of the relations between
ankara and riyadh
and rasool are we actually expecting
anything concrete to come out of this
meeting
well now in turkey with a soaring uh
inflation that is exceeding 70 and an
economic crisis just a year before the
presidential election ankara is hoping
to to sign a a currency swap deal with
riyadh by this way that it can ease the
pressure on the economy and also to
secure the saudi investments in the
country and in return saudi arabia is
facing increasing challenges from iran
and its proxies in the region so saudi
arabia is is seeking to acquire turkey's
biracter drones which have gained
an international acclaim over their
widespread use in libya syria
nagorno-karabakh and now in ukraine so
today a turkish official that i have
spoken to said that this uh the the
visit of crown prince is going to
complete this normalization of the or
the normalization of the relations
between the
the two uh countries so the wizard is
going to signal whether these
aspirations from both sides are going to
be achieved and whether the improvement
of the relationship between ankara and
riyadh is going to be that much big
thank you for that rasool sarah there
for us in ankara